hair-based discrimination is now illegal
in nevada
governor steve seslak signed the crown
act into law this june
the crown act stands for creating a
respectful and open world for natural
hair
bianca holman explains the impact of
this new legislation
hair is a form of expression identity
and a connection to heritage
especially in the black community for me
hair is an accessory you should be able
to wear it how you want
it's beautiful though it's a very like
night and day type of thing if it's wet
the shrinkage is
one way when it's blow-dried it's
another way for many black women there's
a shared experience growing up
memories of straightening coily and
curly hair through the use of chemicals
or heat
often times in order to fit a european
beauty standard yindra dixon who works
in a professional setting
says she was met with comments from
former co-workers during her hair
journey definitely microaggressions can
i touch it
you know what did you do you know when
when black women put in braids all of a
sudden it's like oh my gosh you know
what happened to your hair
because it has transitioned into
something completely different black
women are 80 percent more likely to have
changed their hair from its natural
state to fit into the office
and they're also one and a half times
more likely to be sent home from work
because of their hair that's according
to the 2019 dove crown
research study professional stylists say
the pressure to conform is
damaging and we're stylists we don't
want to straighten that much we'll tell
you like don't put that machine on your
hair
it's going to damage your hair you're
going to lose your hair senators dina
neal and dallas harris
pushed for the crown act protecting
those who wear hair styles like braids
locks and twists people lack education
when it comes to hair
we are typically judged based off
how our hair looks people who don't
understand
maybe have only had the influences of
their families they take those biases
into the workplace
the crown act is life-changing i think
it's super important i think it's
amazing
as we break the chains of slavery as we
liberate
ourselves as a people as we liberate
ourselves as a community
and as we work with our allies to bring
equity and justice
to um to our community it is imperative
that we
let black women be free that we let them
do what they want with their hair
bianca holman 8 news now